even the gods are capable of sustaining
an injury just ask thor's eye
well the cast have had their share of
painful experiences on set too
stick around and you'll also hear about
chris's son's unfortunate tumble on the
avengers set
number 1. chris had a bad back but he
bounced back chris hemsworth injured his
back while filming the newest
installment thor love and thunder while
he was in and out of the hospital in
less than a day he did receive cortisone
injections for the injury this isn't the
first time chris has had back troubles
he said on certain days when i've had a
few injuries and i had quite a few
during thor it can start to become a
drag you know but over the past year or
so i changed up a lot of my training and
nutrition program and i feel the best
i've ever felt you look the best you've
ever looked to chris you even beat a
personal record since being voted the
sexiest man alive in 2014
number two get buff but also get
balanced you know who went unscathed
during the entire filming process for
thor love and thunder even with all of
those rigorous stunts natalie portman
her workout regime was rigorous too she
worked out consistently for five months
leading up to the film and to keep in
top physical condition continued to work
out while filming for the next five
months her trainer said we also worked
on stability and agility for injury
prevention as natalie had some dynamic
stunt scenes that required her to move
twist and land in various positions and
her trainer was also really pleased she
got through the challenging stunt
process without any injuries
number three you know that recurring
nightmare you have it happened to jaime
alexander in thor the dark world jaime
slipped down a metal staircase and did
some serious damage she recalled it was
raining it was dark outside it was like
five in the morning and i went down a
metal staircase and slipped and slipped
a disc in my thoracic spine and chipped
11 of my vertebrae i knocked my left
shoulder out of place and tore my
rhomboid on my right side it took me out
of filming for a month
number four now watch me whip
now watch me regret it in the first thor
movie chris hemsworth borrowed loki's
whip and regretted it almost immediately
upon hitting himself in the face don't
touch other people's props what can we
say
number five tom was seeing asgard after
this one in the first movie a fight
scene between chris and tom resulted in
tom's seeing stars you could literally
freeze frame the moment something went
awry
during the fourth take in a moment where
loki is supposed to spear thor but thor
dodges it grabs the spear and hits loki
in the face tom got a little bit too
close i felt the full force of the
hemsworth elbow
in my face number six like father like
son inspired by his dad's heroics on the
set of the avengers one of chris
hemsworth's twin boys left out of a golf
cart and broke his leg hemsworth recalls
he's kind of half crying sulking more
embarrassed that he didn't stick the
landing but chris also recalled he gets
the cast off a day or two later i'm
cooking dinner and he's standing on the
bench top and he's like papa look my
leg's better he leaps off the bench a
perfect landing that's one proud dad and
if you weren't already aware chris's
whole family has made an appearance in
love and thunder his wife was in a
previous thor film as the stand-in for
natalie portman and she came back to
play a wolf woman and their twins
tristan played a young thor and sasha
one of the asgardian kids and of course
we can't forget that chris's daughter
india played gore's daughter but she had
to audition for that role number seven
the taxing mind games that nails can
play is not to be questioned in love and
thunder the god butcher was going insane
wearing fake nails christian bale
couldn't eat and at times he just felt
like he was immobile too the nails were
definitely playing tricks on his mind
and it was driving him up the wall he
said it made me completely incapable of
everything it was pathetic i found
myself thinking things like i don't
think i can walk because i have long
fingernails it affected my brain i was
like i can't eat i have long fingernails
when i tried to write i couldn't i could
not do anything those nails were a
danger to himself and everyone on set
number eight sometimes you just gotta go
for it fake slapping hemsworth just
wasn't coming off as authentic so after
about 30 attempts portman just had to go
at it and actually slap hemsworth across
the face we bet it was satisfying number
9. tom was losing his marbles wearing
the helmet that's the real reason why it
made fewer appearances in later movies
tom said it was extremely hot because we
were all wearing a lot of armor we were
wearing leather pants and breastplates
and shoulder plates and bicep plates and
the cape was very heavy tom calls the
helmet the steel balaclava saying and
all the heat that's coming through your
body that would normally get out through
your head can't get out through your
head so my brain would slowly fry and
sometimes that would really feed what i
was doing i would be kind of going mad
in there way to use your unfortunate
circumstances to your advantage tom
taking that sucker off must have been a
huge relief we imagine it feels a lot
like letting your hair out of a ponytail
at the end of a long long day number 10.
now if anybody should play annie it's
this guy because it's truly the hard
knock life for him why would anyone ever
want to be a stunt double you're
literally the punching bag of the
production bobby holland hanton has been
injured a ton filming thor he said the
nature of what we do is dangerous but
what we try to do is eliminate as much
danger as we can with time and
rehearsals and yes while time and
rehearsals help they aren't the answer
to everything and sometimes the mats
have to be stripped away and the doubles
just have to take that hard hit bobby
admitted it's just part and parcel of
what we do and we know those risks well
he hurt himself pretty freaking bad in
thor ragnarok he snapped his groin off
the bone by doing a jumping kick flip to
try and kick the hulk in the gladiator
scene they did a rehearsal and the hulk
is so much taller and so bobby had a
wire assist to manage the kick between
the wires and bobby going all out he
hyper-extended and snapped a bit of his
adductor longus the inner thigh and
rectus abdominus i.e the abs right off
the bone so yeah that took a while to
heal number 11. this poor guy just can't
catch a break
such as life for stunt doubles bobby
holland hampton chris's stunt double was
really struggling with putting on the
pounds of muscle for thor love and
thunder chris was bigger than ever and
it's been really taxing on bobby to not
only eat every two freaking hours but
also he said i find carrying around the
extra weight is difficult and hard to
maintain on the ligaments but he's all
good look at him he's a man mountain
number 12. tom must be a good actor if
he can calm an anxious artist with just
a look brianna darnell who was the
stand-in for sophia's sylvian loki was
suffering from a brain injury she'd
received previously and found herself
having a flare-up on set this flare-up
kept her from remembering even basic
choreography it got bad enough that tom
had to tell her what to do and where to
go as her anxiety was going through the
roof and she was near a panic attack tom
took her by the shoulders and just
looked in her eyes with such a gentle
gaze at the time she didn't realize this
was part of the scene
and definitely just thought he was being
kind and trying to calm her panic attack
which hey hiddleston's an intune actor
he would have been responding to her
organically and most definitely picked
up on the anxiety and tried to solve the
problem
either way it was pretty sweet of tom to
be so in tune with his acting partner
we're genuinely surprised there weren't
more ridiculous injuries given the
antics hemsworth likes to get up to
sometimes what's the most ridiculous way
you've ever injured yourself let us know
in the comments and thanks for hanging
out with us here at the things